hi there i'm mark drager and my one
minute monday is to embrace competition
so i was speaking to a friend who told
me that he came up with a great idea
then went online to see who else had
done it and seeing that a ton of other
people have already done it he got
discouraged and thought nah that can't
be a good idea i say that if you're
going to go into a marketplace where
there's no one else doing it you're
either the smartest person or you're
doing something that may not work the
better thing to do is to embrace
competition understand that you can go
into a competitive marketplace and do it
better than anyone else learn what
they're doing wrong
go in there and do it better than anyone
else is doing it and if you become a
market leader embrace competition
because you can't just lay back and do
nothing you need to look at what other
people are doing and continually get
better and better and better so if
you're going to go out there if you're
looking for a business idea don't just
wait to come up with an idea that no one
else has come up with look at what
you're passionate about look at what the
other people are doing and make sure
that you're doing it to the best of your
abilities
believe